juan de peralta back from the coved list
we see the numbers 32 games this will be
his first start ever the era at 5.26 10
walks in 25 and two-thirds innings 242
times he has come out of the bullpen in
his career but this is the first time
he's going to be a starter he's going to
be able to tell his grandkids about that
struck him out swinging he only threw 11
pitches one two three
and a behalf seattle nothing yankees
coming to bat on the year to be his 15th
start 3-5 record the 5.15 era gonzalez
is not going to get any speeding tickets
he averages about 89 miles an hour with
his two-seam fastball and look out below
he gives up a lot of home runs
cut on and missed elevates on him
strikeout to anthony rizzo two gone nice
stab by marco gonzalez they get out
number two
paul knocked down by seeger he stays
with it on to first in time so the play
goes 5-3 and for the yanks three up
three down at the end of one tour in his
last two games five for eleven man he
has been something since joining the
ball club next pitch from perala and a
shallow right field and a dunks in for a
base hit now whether they're lasers or
water balloons they're falling for toro
one on one out france a very short lead
at first pitch
is strike three called
tim timmons
is the veteran home plate umpire
and after the pitch he waits a minute
before doing it dramatically pumping out
some other two way
and a right field for a base head toro
is into second base two out single for
louise terrence the mariners have a
couple of men aboard for kelnick aaron
boone's going to his bullpen with two
outs and two on and steven writings will
take over
line
two on one hop to le mayhew throws the
first to end the inning kelnick hit it
on the nose but
lemay who made the grab to the glove
side
no runs two hits
stanton at second gallow at first and
here is glebe torres he set at the belt
the 3-1 pitch
pitch swung on popped up playable left
side jp
make that seeger
with jp behind him catches it shoulder
high takes a look
and
j.p crawford we okay we're good okay
we're getting it out and that's a big
one marco deals high fastball swing and
a miss bulldog tough you bet
watch the first two men and then escapes
aaron judge leads off yankees have not
had a hit yet
off the end of the bat popped it up in
the infield right side toro calling off
france maturo
wins swirling a little bit makes the
catch
that's a big out to get judged
rip and inside third
and it kicks off the side wall and
that'll hold stanton to a single he
makes a big turn
and then scurries back to first
yankee's first hit of the night so a
one-ounce single now here's joey gallo
nice breaking ball they get some tick
and it foul right back to cal rally's
glove who holds on and there is out
number two third strikeout for marco the
1-0 pitch flying on hit down third easy
place zigger goes short way to toro gets
the force and marco pitches out of
another situation marco gonzalez he had
second inning trouble a couple of walks
and stanton and gallo pitched his way
out of it since then he's given up one
base hit no runs the pitch
pitch swung on it hits weakly down the
secret third throws across
plenty of time you get a gashioka
there's two away and again to your poi
gary the weak contact has been
a hallmark of marco's effort here
tonight
one two pitch
fastball swung on hit down to third
backhanded stepped into the throw seeker
throws over in time and that'll do it
how about marco one two three in the
fifth
here's the 3-2
swung on hits the other way softly hit
but it sneaks into right field that ball
had eyes hannigar fights it off into
right field
and he's a board with one out whatever
it takes swing and a miss got him on the
curve ball
seeger down on strikes two away here's
the pitch
swung on line drive left field base hit
ty france wins the battle and the
mariners in business now runners at
first and second
with two outs do not love that
what
that was outstanding
one ball one strike two on here's the
pitch
swung on crack to the right side through
for a base hit here comes henniger he's
being waved around third base he is
going to score the mariners have taken
the lead abraham toro has done it again
smashing a single in the center the
mariners have broken through they lead
one nothing in the sixth inning gotta
love it all coming with two outs
struck him out swinging
so litki is able to get out of it
with just a one run damage we have seen
kind of the marco of old his last few
turns in the rotation and tonight in
particular
there's a base hit
up the middle
yankee's second hit of the night rizzo's
first
one on one out
you can see the yankee fans ready to
cheer and they got their big boys coming
up now judge stanton and gallo
swinging in a mess he got him
right at the bottom of the zone judge
lunging at it he cuts through rizzo
takes second base on the steal but
there's two away and that was a big big
strike out the fourth of the ball game
for marco might be marco's biggest
strikeout this season man that was huge
tying run at second marco from the belt
his 2-2 on the way to stanton swung on
lifted to center field this is playable
back out is crawford calling fort moore
calls him off he makes the catch with
one hand and that is the inning the
brilliance of marco gonzalez continues
he hangs another zero on the board and
the yankees are scoreless through six
runner in scoring position mariners up
one nothing now lewandska is set to go
be an o2 to henager
a weak round ball
to first
rizzo flips to lewisga in time for the
out
and the yankees escaped trouble in the
seventh no runs one hit too left marco's
still on he has been excellent six
sendings to work two hits
no runs allowed two walks and four
punches
one two
there's a base hit over the leaping try
of france
hanukkah bobbles but staying put at
first base is a glamour tourist i think
he's third hit runner goes here's the
pitch swinging a mess he got him throw
to second base it is not in time just a
tad late but he gets the punch out or
door goes down on strikes there's now
two away what a night for marco gonzalez
he was absolutely brilliant
he'll walk off the mound so far holding
the yankees to no runs here in the
seventh big big spot coming up labor
tours at second base two outs
here's his pitch
swung on ground ball chopped right to
kyle seeger scoops it up off the dirt
throws to first base him plenty of time
and that is the out the mariners turn
away the yankees again here in the
seventh inning as joe smith gets the out
gardner at second la mayhew at first no
one out and that brings up rizzo
castillo deals and that hits rizzo to
load the bases yankees have the bases
loaded and no one out trailing by one in
the eighth inning
that one is lined to left field and it
is going to be caught by more tagging is
gardner he'll score it's a sack fly for
judge we're all tied up at one
there's stanton still hardly out of the
woods got a new game at 1-1
big right hand here first pitch swing on
bounce to the short side crawford over
to toro for one the first double play
stanton hearing it and castillo gives up
just one run we go to the night so the
winning run is at second that's glebe
torres bottom of the ninth 1-1 game the
3-2 pitch
pops it up
going back is toro calls off henniger
going extra innings good job by second
rider the strand two the mariners are
five and nine in extra innings the
yankees are five and seven
chad green will face the top of the
mariner order with a runner on second
nobody out
ripped into right field that's a base
head murphy around third base he's being
waived he's gonna score and the mariners
have the lead jp crawford coming through
big time in extra innings the mariners
have taken the lead it is 2-1 in the
10th inning and eric swanson will come
on and try to close it out for seattle
this will be his 18th game
first and second two out
and that one is looped into right center
field that's gonna be a base hit here
comes gardner he'll score
the yankees have tied the game at two on
the stanton rbi single with two outs
gardner had a chance to win it in the
bottom of the ninth inning first and
second two outs chance to be a hero here
in the 11th and send everybody home and
the pitch
line to base hit to center field here
comes gallow he'll round third here's
the throw here's the play yankees win
three to two brett gardner the longest
tenured yankee he walks it off and the
yankees win it in 11 3-2
you